we are taking calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50
let's take our next call coming in via
Skype always a little bit of a risky
endeavor caller what's your name and
where you calling from mmm hello hi hi
how are you good how are you doing good
you're on the air okay I was just
wondering if you guys hadn't seen movies
the zeitgeist and if so what are your
thoughts on it I saw a bunch of the
different zeitgeist movies years ago
yeah and some of the stuff I think is
pretty interesting with regard to
economics and and some other areas it
also has some pretty conspiratorial
aspects to it right I saw I think
probably the first movie and they opened
with a religion segment that I enjoyed
and learned a lot from and then the very
next segment had to do with 9/11
conspiracy theories and I tuned out at
that point what do you think about the
zeitgeist movies oh like I think it like
it makes a lot of sense and I don't know
I'm just a big fan of Peter Joseph and a
lot of stuff he says makes sense to me
is there if you just agree with anything
that you've seen in those movies or are
there some aspects that you question I
think you spot-on with the money and
like how that how sort of like
structuralism kind of governs everything
he's had some lectures like a pretty
in-depth but he he speaks better on it
than I do but I think a lot of what he
says make sense and are you concerned by
some of the more conspiracy theory stuff
um sort of I just think or maybe you
believe that by curacy theories I don't
um yeah um well some some of it but like
I think like he makes sense looks like
everything like happens for a reason
it's like relational it's not like
um there's not like bad apples there's
it's all part of the system kind of but
I was wondering to see you guys had seen
in know is there a particular conspiracy
theory that you do subscribe to um money
is the root of all evil I guess
is that a conspiracy or sort of like a
proverb I'm not sure I don't know but
like so for example a mantra you believe
we landed on the moon right yeah you do
and you did you believe that Paul
McCartney died and was replaced by a
similar-looking left-handed bassist on
the Beatles probably not okay and do you
think 9/11 you think 9/11 were inside
job uh yes you do okay so we've gotten
with only every other smart talent then
we've gotten very quickly to sort of
like a key area where we would not agree
so all right well listen thanks so much
for the call glad we were able to figure
out I mean I took it I could have
started with 9/11 conspiracy theory but
I opted to go with it third because I
had a sense that we were going to get a
yes on that one right those first two
conspiracy theories are not as popular
as they once were
yes they're not